consid dit non la vérité est ce que tu
as vu des magouilles dans la star ac oui
ou non
ou tu nous dis non 0 magouilles dont
nous en met plein les fouilles se croit
déjà oui aussi al'annonce de cet article
qui est paru aujourd'hui tu es resté
pote avec georges à l'amp
ça fait longtemps qu'on ne s'est pas vu
d'accord on fait on se fait des réunions
repas avec tous tes meilleurs vous
devrez c'est à dire des pensions des
ouvres d'accord j'en étais toi et on se
revoit tous alors c'est vrai que georges
alain et moi présent ou alors on se rate
sur ces rendez vous après mon aventure
que j'ai vécu j'ai vécu moi c'était
comme une grande colonie de vacances
donc si vous voulez c'est vrai que quand
on est sorti ça a été la folie à aucun
moment donné moi je me suis mis en face
d'eux de la télé chez mes parents me
disant bon alors on va re visionner puis
eux
alors moi pour le coup les histoires de
2,2 quotidienne qui était plus diriger
les mâles et honnêtement je ne sais pas
j'ai pas regardé
tu crois ce que dit georges alain ou pas
moi je trouve ça dingue parce que la
partie comme ça mais pas du tout
jean-michel mais comment ne pas croire
georges-alain quel intérêt il à dire ça
il est l intérieur on parle donc pas le
respect que lui et l'a vécue de
l'intérieur histoire et nous on en train
de dire non ils arrivent avec des gens
de la star ac' nathalie andré g
l'adorent voilà la base est bonne le
drap d'or c'est une femme extraordinaire
on l'a beaucoup et c'est parce que je
laime que je que je ne peux pas imaginer
une demi seconde que ce va troquer parce
que nathalie c'est une fille vraiment
droite par ailleurs en revanche ce que
dit benjamin sur le fait que oui les
milliers des magnétos qu'on pouvait
orienter c'est à dire que si on a un
candidat mais c'est moi que ça et qu'il
ya les votes ouverts à cavan non mais
les ritournelles d'avancé sur moi c'est
ça c'est sûr et certain
ça c'est sûr et je crois alors pour le
coup je crois pas du tout c'est bien
possible que dès le début et qui
commence l'édition
c'est vous